tout d'abord tu conseilles de bien
dormir ça veut dire quoi bien dormir
alors ça on a parlé du stress et c'est
vrai qu'on est tous stressé il y a pas
une personne qui n'est pas stressé dans
la vie et ça fait partie d'une réaction
normale à l'organisme notre ancêtre
devait être stressé face à de potentiels
dangers pour soit se battre soit fuir
donc ça on vit avec le stress c'est
normal en revanche ce qui est
problématique c'est le stress qui va
être prolongé chronique qui va avoir un
retentissement sur vos activités on sait
que vous allez sécréter à ce moment-là
beaucoup d'adrénaline et de cortisol et
que sur le long terme ce stress est
délétère on va parler du sommeil mais un
truc tout bête qu'on peut tous faire
pour diminuer le stress c'est des
Japonais qui ont montré cette étude 15
minutes de marche dans une forêt ça
permet de baisser la tension artérielle
la fréquence radio
puisque on s'est rendu compte que ça
baisse aussi le cortisol et si vous me
dites on peut pas tous aller en forêt
c'est vrai mais le fait de s'exposer 3 à
5 minutes par jour à un espace vert quel
qu'il soit des arbres une rivière peu
importe ce que vous avez autour de vous
et bien ça permet de diminuer l'anxiété
la douleur et le stress et déjà observer
on parle beaucoup des jeunes qui sont en
difficulté qui sont un peu stressés que
les jeunes qui ont une fenêtre qui donne
accès sur un jardin sur de la verdure et
bien de meilleure capacités de
concentration que ceux qui ont accès
simplement à un espace urbain donc ça
veut dire que dans l'environnement
urbain on est stressé et qu'on a besoin
de se ressourcer on parle souvent de
l'air de la campagne mais en fait c'est
pas une idée reçue c'est la réalité on
se sent mieux loin des grandes villes
donc on peut se ressourcer tout
simplement en sortant en se baladant en
coupant on parlait des réseaux sociaux
un peu les réseaux sociaux qui en fait
sont pas tellement social sont plutôt
antisociales et on a besoin d'amis
devrait un ou deux ça suffit largement
pas besoin d'avoir plein de followers
par nuit ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
déjà il faut savoir qu'on n'est pas tous
égaux face au sommeil bien sûr certains
ont besoin de 4 heures Emmanuel Macron
apparemment dort très peu bien sûr
Donald Trump dormait très peu et
d'autres ont besoin de dormir beaucoup
donc une façon simple déjà c'est comment
je me réveille le matin et ce que je
mets beaucoup de temps à me réveiller et
surtout le week-end est-ce que j'ai
besoin de compenser une éventuelle de
sommeil si vous devez faire trois quatre
heures de grasse matinée le samedi et le
dimanche ça veut dire attention tout le
reste de la semaine ça ne va pas et puis
n'oubliez pas que notre cerveau
lorsqu'on est fatigué et bien il reçoit
moins bien les informations de notre
oreille de nos yeux de l'odorat de nos
membres et on sait que notamment les
soldats ou les personnels soignants en
fin de journée et moins performant plus
lent donc si on se rend compte qu'on se
traîne un peu que les enfants le soir
ont du mal à terminer leur assiette qui
sont un peu de mauvaise humeur qui
commence à pleurer pour un oui pour un
nom et bien ça veut dire qu'il manque de
sommeil c'est des signes indirects qui
nous font dire qu'il faut aller se
reposer un petit peu
de stress moi je suis stressé ça se
transforme en insomnie et ça c'est
terrible comme plein de français c'est à
dire que je m'endors et à 4h du matin je
me réveille après c'est fini qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire dans ces cas-là
[Rires]
c'est vrai que beaucoup se plaignent de
troubles du sommeil et quand on
enregistre quand on enregistre des gens
qui dorment très bien et comprend les
mêmes personnes qui disent se plaindre
de troubles du sommeil et qu'on regarde
combien de temps ils ont dormi combien
de fois ils se sont réveillés et ben en
fait les deux sommeil sont identiques la
seule chose c'est la perception qu'on a
de notre sommeil et l'anxiété qu'on va
accumuler durant la journée nous laisse
croire qu'on a peut-être mal dormi donc
avant de dire je ne dors pas il faut
comprendre pourquoi et traiter un
éventuel stress plutôt que de prendre
des somnifères qui vont avoir pour effet
un effet amnésian vous allez donc
oublier que vous avez mal dormi donc ne
prenez pas de trucs pour dormir essayez
de comprendre et de jouer sur ce stress
pour essayer de mieux dormir le premier
conseil c'était bien dormir bien dormir
ça veut dire voilà c'est selon les
personnes il y a des personnes qui ont
besoin de 4 heures de sommeil 8 heures
mais vous déconseillez les somnifères
parce qu'en fait on va avoir
l'impression d'avoir dormi mais en fait
on aura mal dormi exactement
le sport le meilleur et en particulier
alors chez tout le monde mais si vous
avez des parents des grands-parents qui
ont du mal à dormir on sait avec le
temps et bien on a des phases du sommeil
qui sont un peu plus courtes notamment
une phase qu'on appelle le sommeil lent
profond ce sommelant profond normalement
permet de s'endormir et de ne pas se
réveiller durant la nuit et on sait que
la personne âgée avec le temps après 65
ans et bien elle va avoir moins de
sommeil en profonde une façon simple
d'augmenter ce sommeil en profonde quand
tu dormais avec Nico
l'argent c'est le marché une heure par
jour on se rend compte que les personnes
âgées qui vont marcher une heure par
jour elles-mêmes vont mieux dormir donc
oui l'activité physique elle est
bénéfique pour mieux dormir c'est
valable à la fois chez les enfants mais
aussi chez les adultes et les personnes
un peu âgées qu'est-ce qu'il y a dans sa
tanière malouve non j'ai une question
moi je vois beaucoup de café toute la
journée jusqu'à quelle heure on peut
boire du café sans que ça nous mette en
danger pour notre sommeil c'est du mytho
absolument c'est du mytho on peut boire
du café même à 22h ça c'est une idée
reçue que le café on a tous une
sensibilité à la caféine et d'ailleurs
ceux qui seraient un peu plus répondeur
à caféine si le matin vous avez
absolument besoin d'un café pour vous
réveiller si après le déjeuner vous avez
besoin d'un café ça veut dire finalement
que vous ne résistez pas beaucoup à la
fatigue et ça c'est une prédisposition
génétique et il y a des gens à 22h qui
peuvent prendre un café une strictement
rien se passer et à l'inverse certains à
partir de 14h s'il prennent un café
c'est game over donc ça veut dire qu'il
faut connaître son corps et qu'il n'y a
pas de règle et que le canapé le café
pardon est bénéfique pour sa santé quel
que soit la dose que vous prenez sans
entraîne pas d'effet secondaire et
parfois on a le cœur qui bat un peu vite
voilà alors deuxième conseil ne pas
pouvoir ne pas boire de boissons
énergisantes oui exactement ça dans
l'ambiance du café moi quand j'étais
étudiant je me souviens je me suis je
connaissais pas tous ces trucs là et je
me suis dit il faut absolument que je
sois performant on a tous connu ça il
faut que on y aille on va boire du café
du raid machin truc la boisson qui donne
des ailes on va prendre du buronzant et
sauf qu'on se rend compte que ces
boissons et bien elles vont juste vous
exciter elles sont excitantes le café va
augmenter un peu la pression artérielle
les boissons énergisantes elles donnent
des calories elles mettent de la caféine
sont parfois bourré d'édulcorants de
faux sucres et donc vous allez juste
avoir le cœur qui palpite vous allez
vous sentir très mal et ça va au
contraire vous brouiller si vous avez
besoin de consommer énormément de
boissons énergisantes c'est que vous
êtes fatigué ces cas-là il y a pas 10000
trucs il faut dormir et fermer sa gueule
et c'est valable aussi pour les
étudiants qui veulent réussir leurs
examens qui font des nuits blanches si
vous travaillez durant toute la nuit et
bien la nuit c'est un phénomène actif
vous n'allez pas enregistrer les
acquisitions que vous avez eu au cours
de la journée c'est contre-production
d'acheter des trucs on va oublier alors
si on a si on si on a essayé si on a
travaillé très dur de 15 heures à 18h et
bien c'est peut-être plus efficace que
de travailler de 22h à 2h du matin mieux
vaut de dormir c'est 4 heures que vous
allez gâcher
vous voulez travailler bosser bosser
bosser je ne dormais plus
étudié tout le temps et en fait un
moment je me suis il faut que
diverses choses c'est quelle école tu as
fait une thèse c'était quoi le dans quel
sujet l'intitulé de la thèse en Amazonie
[Applaudissements]
qui prend beaucoup de boissons énergies
il y a que Guillaume et Nino d'accord
toi Clément toi
est-ce que le est-ce que le café fait
partie des Bossons énergisantes oui on
peut le
constaterine sauf que dans ces boissons
énergisantes il y a aussi de la caféine
donc si vous prenez un café et qu'en
plus vous prenez ces boissons
énergisantes
je vous dis 95% des Français déclarent
avoir moins au moins une grande source
de stress 3e concert ça y faire la
sieste même une micro-sieste
mais c'est une très bonne chose même 10
minutes tu vois mais même 10 minutes au
restaurant
j'ai dormi 10 minutes et quand vous vous
réveillez vous êtes un mauvais
et on peut même aller un tout petit peu
avant c'est ce que faisait Einstein et
Salvador Dali
ensemble
Eurêka le principe est simple Salvador
Dali avait une cuillère dans la main il
s'allongeait il essaie de s'endormir au
moment il s'endort il lâche la cuillère
au moment où on lâche la cuillère elle
tombe par terre elle fait du bruit et
elle vous réveille cette étape
intermédiaire entre la veille le fait de
dormir et d'être réveillé c'est le
moment où on va être le plus productif
et c'est là on va résoudre des problèmes
si vous avez un problème vous n'avez pas
ça et bien cette petite photo
et parfois j'ai des trucs tu vois et qui
viennent comme ça et ben en fait ça vous
verrez que vous allez résoudre plein de
problèmes à la fois dans la vie la cuire
tomber là on se réveille et la BIM et
bah c'est un vrai
[Rires]
c'est quand même extrêmement dur de
s'endormir d'abord sur commande en
milieu de journée et le réveil moi je
trouve douloureux c'est à dire que on a
le sentiment qu'on est réveillé
mais ça veut dire que en fait lorsque
vous vous réveillez et que vous êtes
vraiment dans le coltar c'est que vous
avez dormi trop longtemps et que vous
êtes vous êtes dans une phase du sommeil
plus longue et plus lourde donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut se réveiller un tout
petit peu avant et un conseil que je
donne dans le livre c'est de prendre
éventuellement un café le jour où vous
devez absolument être productif vous
prenez un café vous allez faire la
sieste le café va mettre 10 à 15 minutes
avant de faire effet vous réveillez
juste après de la sieste en étant en
pleine forme parce qu'il y a la caféine
qui aura fait effet et puis l'effet de
l'assiette sera bénéfique on appelle ça
un apuccino take up faire une sieste et
prendre un capuccino et des sportifs le
fonds
il fait ce truc là alors c'est usé de
façon ponctuelle parce que si en
permanence vous faites ça c'est que vous
avez un problème de sommeil c'est café
après c'est compliqué mais ça nous
réveille au bout de 15 minutes donc
c'est une façon de plonger dans une
phase du sommeil on va mettre on va
dormir 25 minutes une heure et après on
est très mal alors quatrième conseil
avoir une alimentation saine ça ça là
c'est quoi une alimentation saine est-ce
que tout le monde dit avoir une
alimentation saine moi je comprends pas
ce que c'est alors moi elle a une
alimentation saine pour moi c'est pizza
hamburger pâtes
chocolat alors il faut bien comprendre
que quand on mange on à la fois pour se
faire plaisir et aussi pour notre santé
et notre corps il y a des expériences
qui ont été menées notamment chez la
souris on peut extrapoler chez l'être
humain à savoir qu'on va prendre des
souris qui vont bien et on va leur nous
on va les nourrir avec un régime type
fast-food hamburger j'ai vu Mickey la
dernière fois lorsqu'on fait ça
devient déprimé puisqu'on peut évaluer
tu viens on va chercher du fromage non
ça me casser
l'alimentation a eu un impact sur l'état
moral de la souris c'est la même chose
chez les hommes et quand on prend sa
souris et qu'on va prendre leur
microbiote c'est-à-dire leur bactéries
qu'on va transférer à une souris qui
n'est pas déprimée et ben juste ce
transfert de microbiote ça déprime la
nouvelle souris ça veut dire que
l'alimentation a un véritable impact à
la fois sur notre santé d'une façon
générale il y a l'Institut national des
souris à la maison on leur donne des
trucs à Gémeaux et elles vont des
raisons je suis déprimé viens on se
barre quoi c'est pour ça qu'on parle
d'alimentation Ant inflammatoires vous
en avez beaucoup parlé de ça c'est le
régime méditerranéen si vous avez une
alimentation la moins ultra transformée
possible bannissez autant que possible
les aliments que vous allez acheter
directement près notamment dans les
supermarchés il faut acheter des trucs
simples c'est la base des fruits et des
légumes boire de l'eau évitez les sodas
même ceux avec des édulcorants des faux
sucres une étude récente montre que la
consommation de ces faux sucres j'étais
venu parler de ces faux sucres en disant
ça permet pas de perdre du poids ça sert
à rien et bien on s'est rendu compte
dans une énorme cote de 100 000 patients
que ceux qui vont boire ces faux sucres
dans les boissons light et bien font
plus de maladies cardiovasculaires plus
de maladies cérébrovasculaires que les
autres donc ça veut dire que ces
boissons qu'on dit safe en réalité elle
pose problème donc revenez à une
alimentation simple et là il y a
l'Institut national de recherche contre
le cancer qui dit que l'alimentation a
un impact sur le cancer qu'on pourrait
avoir ou surtout qu'on pourrait éviter
donc ça veut dire qu'en mangeant des
fruits et des légumes ça c'est la base
c'est vrai qu'on saoule tout le monde
avec ça mais c'est une vérité c'est
comme ça qu'on restera en bonne santé
est-ce que ça veut dire Jimmy qui a des
aliments anti-cancer quand même on peut
alors c'est vrai que j'aime pas ce
principe d'alimenter
du prenait du curcuma oui on parle du
brocoli c'est vrai le brocoli c'est très
bien mais c'est une alimentation la plus
simple possible mais malgré tout il faut
bien comprendre que on a une révolution
industrielle qui fait que sur les 20 ou
30 dernières années notre alimentation a
été bouleversée par les produits tout
près qui coûte parfois un peu moins cher
qu'on peut garder très longtemps sauf
que notre microbiote ne sait pas adapté
à cette révolution et c'est ce qui fait
qu'on a un peu plus d'obésité qu'on a
plus de maladies cardiovasculaires plus
de diabète donc vous faites ce que vous
voulez mais au moins vous avez la
formation et on peut peut-être
équilibrer le jour où vous faites un
excès vous dites que ok le lendemain je
vais peut-être faire un peu de jeunes
intermittents peut-être manger un peu
mieux on fait un petit équilibre mais
tout ça
et une matinée
alors il faut faire des pauses au
travail alors vous ça vous concerne pas
vous ça vous concerne pas vous êtes
toujours en pause euh mais pour les gens
qui travaillent les gens qui nous
regardent qui travaillent vraiment il
faut faire des pauses au travail
exactement moi j'ai du mal à faire des
pauses de travail et pourtant forcement
j'ai du mal à trouver le temps les
études montrent que 40 secondes à
quelques minutes de pause augmente la
productivité donc 40 secondes de 30
secondes il y a quelques minutes
j'arrive à mon patron qui me parle 2
minutes 40 secondes exactement mais 40
secondes à faire quoi à pas être sur le
téléphone et regarder ce qui se passe
sur Instagram sur Twitter allez marcher
faire une pause avec des collègues ça
aérer l'esprit et bien ça améliore la
productivité souvent on a la tête dans
le guidon mais c'est quelque pause
permet d'être plus performant ici un
moment vous êtes très fatigué ça c'est
ce que font les commandos marine
lorsqu'ils doivent veiller durant toute
la nuit au bout d'un moment ils sont
fatigués et bien le fait de faire une
activité physique comme des pompes et
bien les pompes vont venir stimuler une
hormone un peu particulière qui va vous
réveiller et si comme Benham on achète
des pompes
quand on en manque on souffre d'une
pathologie du sommeil qu'on appelle la
narcolepsie c'est des gens qui ont
tendance à s'endormir assez facilement
et on sait que lorsque vous faites une
activité physique comme des pompes vous
courrez vous marchez vous faites ce que
vous voulez vous allez produire cette
orexine qui va vous réveiller donc on
fait des pauses on sert l'esprit et on
va un peu loin du téléphone si on peut
qu'est-ce qui se passe non j'adore le
conseil mais j'imagine mal au bureau un
mec il faut l'accepter comment ça
envoyer des pompes
il faut libérer l'orexine et dernière
chose Cyril alors moi je fais pas de
placement de produit je fais juste des
placements de livres ce que je vous ai
dit ça c'est pas toi en plus non c'est
pas moi j'ai rien à gagner alors acheter
un peu mon livre si vous voulez pour
mettre la daronne à l'abri voilà ok
franchement c'est des livres que dans
lequel vous avez trouvé toutes les
études dont j'ai parlé c'est
extraordinaire les émotions du
dérèglement climatique c'est Antoine
pélisselot aux éditions Flammarion
j'adore
déjà fait avec le docteur Selim Massini
exactement
il est hyper abîmé j'ai même de la
chorba dessus parce que je lis tout le
temps
en quatre semaines on s'est retrouvé 100
% de votre énergie grâce au soleil
anti-philippe en compagnie
et Michel le joyeux
prof de médecine il écrit un livre où il
donne des astuces tout simple comme par
exemple la consommation de champignons a
un effet antidépresseur ce qui consomme
des champignons quelques grammes par
jour sont moins déprimés que les autres
donc vous allez apprendre plein de trucs
du quotidien des champignons
[Rires]
en bonne santé avec mon teigne j'adore
bravo
[Applaudissements]
parce que Montaigne c'est quelqu'un qui
compte beaucoup pour moi
non mais c'est vrai et voilà donc
j'adore Kevin Montaigne
merci en tout cas merci à vous merci à
vous